[Música]
el papá francisco puso fin a los
privilegios de una de las instituciones
más poderosas dentro de la iglesia
católica el opus dei así las cosas la
prelatura fundada por josemaría escrivá
de balaguer ahora deberá rendir cuentas
y su líder no podrá ser obispo veamos un
extracto de la carta que publicó el
vaticano haciendo este anuncio
cada año el prelado someter al
dicasterio para el clero un informe
sobre el estado de la prelatura y sobre
el desempeño de su labor apostólica
ahora deberá rendir cuentas entonces al
vaticano desde el opus dei- respondieron
a este anuncio hecho por el sumo
pontífice desde el vaticano a través de
una carta a fernando ocáriz el sacerdote
y actualmente al frente del opus dei-
como prelado dijo lo siguiente veamos
en cuanto a las disposiciones del motu
propio sobre la figura del prelado os
repito lo que os he enseñado otras veces
damos gracias a dios por los frutos de
comunión eclesial que han significado
los episcopados del beato álvaro y de
don javier al mismo tiempo la ordenación
episcopal del prelado no era ni es
necesaria para la guía del opus dei- la
voluntad del papá de subrayar ahora la
dimensión carismática de la obra nos
invita a reforzar el ambiente de familia
de cariño y confianza el prelado ha de
ser guía pero ante todo padre
la decisión que ha tomado el papá
francisco supone o no un duro golpe para
los pilares de esta organización o hace
parte de un intento del papá francisco
por renovar un poco las estructuras de
la iglesia y poner un poco más bajo
control al opus dei- al tener que dar
cuentas sobre sus finanzas sobre las
instituciones educativas y los manejos
al interior de esta organización así
como de la forma como se hace frente
también a los escándalos como el más
reciente por explotación de mujeres hay
quienes dicen y lo dicen en un tono
bastante especulativo que estas
decisiones del vaticano obedecen también
a esa escasa sintonía que hay entre el
papá francisco y esta organización que
es conocida por ser extremadamente
conservadora muy rica dentro de la
iglesia católica y que también es
señalada por ser sectaria poderosa y por
su controvertido secretismo hoy en el
debate de france 24 analizamos porque el
papá francisco le quita poder autonomía
al opus dei y qué tan efectivas pueden
ser estas medidas o son simplemente
simbólicas para analizar este tema
saludamos a álvaro ramos él es teólogo y
rector de la universidad academia de
humanismo cristiano él se conecta desde
la ciudad de santiago en chile y desde
valparaíso en la costa chilena se
conecta mike van tres él es doctor en
teología de la universidad católica de
lovaina y también es miembro del cité
que es el círculo de teologías libres
también quiero hacer la aclaración que
la producción de invitados del programa
el debate de france 24 intentó contactar
a personas o representantes del opus dei
para que participaran en este debate
para conocer su punto de vista y no
aceptaron la invitación para venir a
dialogar con nosotros y exponer sus
ideas o puntos de vista sobre este tema
aprovechó entonces también para
recordarles que ustedes hacen parte de
esta conversación pueden dejar sus
preguntas y sus comentarios a través de
las redes sociales estamos en twitter en
instagram y en facebook en donde no se
encuentran como france24 bajo ese arroba
santi logo que es mi cuenta personal la
etiqueta para que dejen sus comentarios
numeral el debate efe 24 en youtube
también pueden seguir nuestra señal en
streaming
para saludar a las personas que nos
están escuchando a través de nuestro
podcast todos los contenidos del debate
de france 24 ya los pueden escuchar en
diferentes plataformas estamos en app el
podcast en spotify deezer y tuning
pues comienza entonces dándole la
bienvenida a álvaro en la ciudad de
santiago álvaro gracias por estar con
nosotros en el programa bienvenido punto
de partida como me gusta llamar a esta
primera pregunta para conocer opiniones
sobre el tema central del programa y esa
pregunta entonces sería porque la
decisión del papá francisco de quitar
estos ciertos privilegios o no son
privilegios como toma usted esta
decisión del papá francisco frente a
esta organización del opus dei
yo creo que efectivamente es una el fin
de un privilegio el privilegio que
representaba también una amenaza para la
propia iglesia siempre se ha comentado
que la figura del pelado personal o la
prelatura personal que se atribuyó al al
opus dei es una anomalía que no tiene
precedentes históricos en la historia de
la iglesia católica y que representa una
amenaza en tanto podía
entenderse como una iglesia dentro de la
iglesia o un reducto fuera del control
de la iglesia de interior de la iglesia
y especialmente cuando
rompe la cadena de mando establecida por
las dioses y cada diócesis y
arquidiócesis y en la iglesia católica
existe un obispo y ese obispo arzobispo
tiene una jurisdicción territorio de
territorial en cambio esta prelatura
personal se establecía como una
especie de obispo sin territorio que
cubría por decirlo así todo el mundo y
que simplemente estaban afectos a ella
quienes escribían a lo podéis
era una especie de espacio del fuero que
tenía cierto privilegio para poderse dar
un cheque en blanco digamos a la
organización
comienzo entonces dándole ahora la
palabra a mike evans traer que en la
ciudad de valparaíso punto de partida la
primera pregunta para conocer opiniones
cómo entender esta decisión del papá
francisco cuál es su opinión mike
bienvenido muchas gracias santiago
si yo coincido con un con álvaro que
efectivamente se trata de la pérdida de
un privilegio
la prelatura suponía no sólo una amenaza
a la colegialidad hacer todas las
inhabilidades
y vamos a la textura de la iglesia sino
que además era una distorsión porque las
creaturas apostólicas personales del
papa fueron y fueron muy pedidas por el
concilio vaticano segundo en los años 60
en el contexto de la guerra fría a fin
de poder enviar sacerdotes a lugares
donde la iglesia católica occidental no
tenía acceso europa del este y otros
lugares
con la finalidad de poder agilizar la
llegada a hacer todo el clero secular a
esos lugares que no es el caso en
absoluto cierto que
no necesita en absoluto cierto ese apoyo
porque ellos mismos han forjado como
decía algo en una iglesia dentro la
iglesia un enorme poder dentro de la
iglesia y de la sociedad y de la
sociedad de las sociedades donde se
instalan porque
la forma en que lo podéis se ha
insertado de manera digamos
importante en muchas sociedades de
américa latina y del sur de europa ha
sido a través de la complicidad con las
élites económicas y políticas
de las cuales también francisco se
siente un poco más que 60 segundos
continuó con usted de mike para hacer la
ronda la inversa de al lado de la
palabra al bar a usted habla de los
privilegios hablemos exactamente cuáles
eran esos privilegios al interior de la
iglesia porque ganó estos privilegios y
también vamos con ustedes dos a entender
cuál es el fin el origen o la motivación
que llevó a la creación del opus dei
para entender lo que muchas personas
oyen hablar de esta de esta organización
a lo largo del día a día pero pero pocas
personas lo entienden y lo ven como una
secta como una organización se le
malinterpreta en cierta forma entonces
pongamos la en perspectiva para poder
entender de qué estamos hablando de
todos comenzó con mike para hablar de
los privilegios y con álvaro hablamos de
esas amenazas para la iglesia católica
adelante mike
claro el privilegio hay que entender la
estructura organizacional de la iglesia
que se superponen diferentes estructuras
para administrar un mismo territorio
estar por ejemplo en las diócesis ya las
diócesis es un ordenamiento territorial
diócesis parroquia etcétera están
después las congregaciones y órdenes
religiosas que son como empresas
transnacionales que se administran de
otra manera con una especie de capas de
capa distinta inconexa con el obispo del
lugar después están los movimientos
apostólicos donde está donde ya estamos
más cercanos los buses los movimientos
apostólicos son como instituciones mucho
más flexibles ya que no tienen relación
con una orden una congregación
necesariamente están mayormente
constituidas por laicos o seglares o
laicas como es el caso del opus dei
y entonces el obispo va viendo diluido
su poder en base a esta organización
territorial finalmente lo puse y es una
especie de diócesis personal
donde hay un prelado que era el que
antes y antiguamente era
obligatoriamente un obispo que
administra por decir así pastoral y
económicamente
la red de algunos sacerdotes que se
adscriben al opus dei y en los seglares
y entonces cuál era el privilegios el
privilegio era no depender de ninguna
otra organización territorial presente
en ello estaba no dependiendo el obispo
no dependían de un superior de una orden
religiosa y entonces constituían una
especie de capa autónoma cuando se puede
hacer y deshacer cierto sin además si
una vez viviente sin rendir cuentas de
de la misión principal que la misión
principal debería ser evangelizar y al
parecer si no lo que se ha detectado con
el tiempo es que la misión principal del
opus dei fue administrar el
neoconservadurismo de juan pablo segundo
y eso ese privilegio es el que acaba de
recibir un golpe
álvaro en la ciudad de santiago le
preguntó entonces por esas amenazas que
se puedan sentir desde el vaticano por
esta organización qué
y acaudalado ha reunido muchísimo dinero
se ha rodeado de personas muy poderosas
y hay que decirlo tiene muchísima fuerza
y peso en las sociedades
latinoamericanas no solamente pues por
mencionar nuestra región
así es es una institución que desde los
años
60 empezó a expandirse fuertemente en
américa latina y ha copado instituciones
educativas de salud organizaciones
también de asistencia social pero sobre
todo en el campo de la por decir masiva
realización de las élites de las élites
particularmente económicas y políticas y
esa misión podría ser legítima si se
hace bajo medios adecuados es decir
nadie puede estar en contra de la libre
asociación de personas en la sociedad y
también dentro de la iglesia el punto es
el secretismo los privilegios el
carácter de esa asociación y muchas
veces se ha traducido se ha criticado
más bien como un una forma de tráfico de
influencias
o de beneficios personales para quienes
acceden a ello en la medida en que al
pertenecer a esa institución pueden
escalar en posiciones de poder o de
riqueza por medio de vínculos
que van siendo cada vez mayor en medida
que haciendo en la pirámide de la
institución
álvaro cuál era el fin al momento de
crearse esta organización cuál era el
fin del opus dei
y en qué momento se empezó como a
tergiversar un poco este organismo
desde su inicio tenía un foco
muy claro de rodearse como usted lo está
mencionando con personas de las élites
de los de las diferentes
sociedades y amasar grandes cantidades
de dinero y también tener un foco en
educación hay muchas universidades en
américa latina que son que pertenecen al
opus dei y cumplen una función educativa
importante en algunos países
bueno el poder no se puede entender sin
el contexto del franquismo es decir la
dictadura franquista
incuba por decirlo así movimientos
católicos que van a
avalando y llegándose al proceso del
franquismo en españa en la novedad del
opus dei fue generar de alguna forma una
legitimación de la participación
protagónica de los laicos y eso siempre
ha sido lo que ellos han defendido como
su sello singular y que creo que es un
aporte en el contexto una iglesia muy
clerical haber defendido el rol
protagónico del laicado sin embargo es
el rol protagónico del laicado muchas
veces estaba más bien en la medida en
que se ha ido creando una figura que fue
bastante confusa porque más que laico
fueron una especie de religiosos sin
votos no hoy día varias mujeres
han denunciado su situación como una
especie de régimen de servidumbre que
les llevó a estar ligadas a la orden o
al movimiento
realizando tareas sin percibir salarios
ni cotizaciones sociales entonces ahí
hay una figura que es un poco extraña y
que sigue siendo motivo de mucha
preocupación debido a que parte de este
entramado digamos de institucional del
opus dei con laicos que tienen
compromisos comunitarios como si fueran
religiosos pero que no son sacerdote
creó una figura bastante extraña de
entender y que puede ser cercano a lo
que podríamos llamar una forma de
esclavitud voluntaria y eso obviamente
en nuestra sociedad no puede ser
permitido claro ya la sociedad actual no
permite ese tipo de de aspectos mike en
la ciudad de valparaíso
me remonto a 1982 una fecha clave un año
clave porque fue cuando el entonces papa
juan pablo segundo le da estos
privilegios a esta organización el era
de un corte muy conservador usted lo
estaba mencionando que se estaría
tratando de estar allí al darle estos
privilegios que era lo que estaba o cómo
se puede interpretar esta acción por
parte del entonces papa juan pablo
segundo
bueno el año 82 es clave porque
es la reforma del derecho canónico que
permite la existencia del andamiaje
jurídico a lo que había propuesto el
concilio vaticano según ya entonces
antes no existían en el código de
derecho canónico anterior de 1917 no
existía la figura y entonces hubo que
esperar hasta que existiese la reforma
al derecho económico para que existiera
la apertura personal y josemaría
el celebra cierto esto que ellos habían
pedido con tanta insistencia para ella
una prelatura efectivamente era la
obtención de un privilegio que no aunque
no digan ahora que no lo era ni que no
lo necesitaban y que no lo querían
porque realmente lo deseaban yo dice
textualmente cierto con todo el argón
del corazón ahora quien lo que sé que
estaba era necesario desde el punto de
vista tecnológico volver a proveer a las
élites de los países una espiritualidad
que fuera acorde con su sentir religioso
tradicional el concilio vaticano segundo
había impulsado una reforma de la
espiritualidad católica una reforma que
ponía a los pobres ser todos los
marginados a los oprimidos del centro
eso obviamente produjo un éxodo de clero
y religiosas y religiosos
desde la atención pastoral de las élites
a la atención pastoral de los pobres no
es la época de las inserciones donde las
religiosas los religiosos ciertos van y
se desplazan de los barrios por decir
así acomodados en la ciudad de las
periferias y la la élite queda huérfana
no queda cómodo sin sin la atención
pastoral pero no la atención pastoral
sacramental queda sin una teología que
lo sustente y entonces vienen los 'bous
de iu con su teología del trabajo que no
es otra cosa que la sacralización de la
división del trabajo neoliberal y
entonces esa división estricta del
trabajo de hombres y mujeres del trabajo
doméstico y el trabajo intelectual
etcétera bueno eso es la espiritualidad
que se le ofrece a la élite se lee el
mensaje final es ustedes pueden seguir
donde están siguiendo exactamente como
siempre y eso es lo que de alguna manera
ahora está empezando a ponerse en
cuestión desde esta
de esta reforma
a sus propias tantos álvaro como
entender esto esto que se ve al interior
de la iglesia este tipo de preferencias
de privilegios claramente al interior
entonces de la iglesia es claro que hay
disputas de poder de las diferentes
organizaciones que hay dentro de la
iglesia católica y el opus dei- empezó
ya lo hemos dicho a cultivar muchísimo
poder al interior de la iglesia y el
papá francisco de papa juan pablo
segundo pues digamos que con esto le da
una diferenciación con respecto a otros
organismos como entender que está ahí
esta religión que habla de igualdad y
que habla de mirar a todos por igual
haya tantas diferencias
escalafones jerarquías de privilegios y
fuera de eso que se ponga a unos por
encima de otros
bueno en la historia de la iglesia
muestra eso de manera muy amplia no
siempre han existido formas digamos de
privilegio a ciertas órdenes oa ciertos
campos a ciertos a ciertos países dentro
de la iglesia católica que han tenido
privilegios por sobre otros los derechos
de conquista por ejemplo para mí para
españa y portugal la gula es carretera o
sea son no son una larga historia es una
larga historia la que puede explicar
como la iglesia ha ido confabulando en
términos de la relación con el poder con
el poder económico y articulando redes
que obviamente se tienen que distribuir
esa distribución del poder es la que le
otorga a ciertos sectores mayores
privilegios la medida que aportan
también más recursos o bienes simbólicos
de estatus de privilegio de
conexión política y que eso obviamente
abre puertas y abre capacidades de poder
incidir en la construcción de una
organización más poderosa que no pude y
en eso ha tenido una maestría enorme
debido a que
prontamente logro tener muchos ministros
en el gabinete de francisco franco en
españa y esos los replicó en muchos
países de américa latina particularmente
una de las dictaduras militares de donde
también colocó a distintos personajes de
su propia de su propia obra en los
gabinetes por ejemplo de augusto
pinochet o de otros dictadores de la
época y después lo han seguido
reproduciendo teniendo una
representación de parlamentario pero a
veces también una fuerte presencia en el
empresariado
álvaro eso no desvirtúa un poco la
misión la esencia de la iglesia católica
bueno es inevitable que una institución
religiosa no esté fuera de la sociedad
eso yo creo que inevitable por decirlo
así la relación activa la vinculación
entre el campo lo religioso y el campo
del siglo así de lo social de lo
económico lo político lo que hay aquí es
un uso una intencionalidad de esa
vinculación con el afán de acumular más
poder y eso obviamente debe ser regulado
y por lo tanto creo que acá el papá
francisco al regular está esta pulsión
por el poder
hace un servicio no sólo la iglesia
católica sino también a las sociedades
mike su opinión sobre sobre esta
pregunta álvaro si esto no desvirtúa un
poco la misión de la iglesia que se
aleja un poco de ese aspecto social y
quiera meterse en aspectos políticos en
aspectos de círculos de poder desvirtuar
el camino
depende como se ve así o sea la ninguna
institución humana ninguna institución
puede existir sin ejercer poder y acá el
tema es como decían de la concentración
del poder y como ese poder de alguna
manera también se le limita y se le se
le vigila se le sanciona y eso es lo que
no había ninguna posibilidad con el opus
dei porque efectivamente cierto era una
institución que tenía prácticamente más
poder que es papá recordemos que durante
el pontificado juan pablo segundo
cualquier navarro valls el vocero de
juan pablo segundo y recordemos que juan
pablo segundo en prácticamente diez años
de su pontificado no hablo no hablaba
era una persona mentada que estaba con
sus facultades muy limitadas cierto y
era joaquín navarro-valls miembro del
obús de ciertos del que hacía de vocero
o sea estamos hablando de eso de una
concentración de poder a nivel
monárquico y eso es lo que efectivamente
hace mucho daño pues que porque si bien
no puede existir
no puede haber luchas de poder al
interior de la iglesia no puede haber no
puede no haber discusión política al
interior de la iglesia esa discusión
tiene que estar atravesada por
el adn del evangelio que es justamente
un adn y bolivaristas no un adn
jerárquico y fíjense que eso es lo que
pide por último lo que pide francisco en
la reforma dice reformar el gobierno
interno de los 'bous débil de manera que
prime la el carisma y no la autoridad
jerárquica ya eso ese proceso para mi
gusto para mi opinión es un proceso en
el proceso más difícil que se le puede
imponer a los buses y más exigentes que
se le puede poner al pp es como es como
decirle a un ejército extremadamente
jerarquizado que se democratice y que
prácticamente de sable que tiene que
refundarse ahora eso requiere por
supuesto mucha energía requiere mucha
vigilancia mucho control mucha
transparencia a la vez lo que que ha
intentado ser francisco con esta reforma
que no es la única que ya le va a
preguntar justamente por esas reformas
que está llevando a cabo el papá
francisco pero antes quería preguntarle
mike en la práctica desde su punto de
vista
estas reformas que le han pedido al opus
dei esta pérdida de estatus
qué tan efectivo va a ser o si es más
simbólico de lo que uno pensaría cuál es
su impresión
lo primero que lo simbólico tiene su
fuerza los simbólicos
ejerce poder es importante porque genera
estatus también genera opinión entonces
es es algo que ya tienes puesto y
segundo yo creo que sí va a tener
va a tener
digamos fuerza y va a poderse llevar
adelante porque hay una reforma de la
curia vaticana que también está en
marcha
ahora cuáles son los tiempos de esa
reforma
va a ser la historia pero como como bien
decía álvaro ramis también depende de
las sociedades de los países donde se ha
implantado el opus dei depende de esas
sociedades también exigirles a esas
asociaciones civiles cosas religiosas
civiles exigirles transparencia y que
cumplan con los estándares de derechos
humanos que deben cumplir toda
organización humana
entonces es un trabajo eclesial y
también un trabajo de la organización
social 'la pero pasemos a eso al tema de
las reformas que está tratando de
avanzar el papá francisco a lo largo de
su pontificado que tan necesarias son
estas reformas que tan rápido está
progresando el papá francisco en estas
reformas que está intentando y cuál es
el norte que le está dando a la iglesia
católica cuál es el panorama que el papá
francisco tiene de cómo debe ser esa
nueva iglesia católica diga cuando así
en un escenario donde la sociedad pues
ha cambiado mucho y trata de ajustarse a
las necesidades de el presente
bueno el papá francisco cumple 10 años
de pontificado y en esta fase creo que
está tratando de consolidar algunas
líneas de trabajo que ha tratado de
impulsar con mayor o menor éxito
en este diseño
un ejemplo de ello ha sido todo el
trabajo de desmontar
redes de poder ligadas a otras
organizaciones similares como los
legionarios de cristo el poder impulsar
cambios en el conceptos teológicos no
tratar digamos de reinterpretar la
tradición de la iglesia para dar mayor
apertura a las minorías particularmente
en temas de sexualidad y abordar también
temas que tienen que ver como por
ejemplo como lo podéis con la es poder
interno de la iglesia obviamente son
reformas que van a quedar
en una primera fase debido a la edad del
papá francisco es probable que esto no
llegue a culminarse todo lo que él tal
vez ha ido
diagnosticando como necesario pero sin
embargo creo que esta es una medida
concreta muy
pragmática que está ajustada al derecho
de la propia iglesia y que instala una
necesidad de cambio en una organización
muy importante dentro del hablar de la
estructura de iglesia católica álvaro
pero lo decía yo en la introducción del
programa hay quienes dicen en ese tono
especulativo que esto obedece
precisamente este cambio a esa falta de
sintonía que hay entre el papá francisco
y la organización del opus dei y le
extiendo un poco más la pregunta si
estas reformas son para darle que sean
reformas que perduren en el tiempo y en
el futuro de la iglesia católica o son
reformas que está llevando a cabo en
particular el papá francisco para
concentrar más poder él como persona
como pontífice y tener al opus dei- un
poco más controlado dentro de su ala
yo creo que es una reforma que busca
normalizar una situación anómala
'cualquier por decirlo así pontífice
cualquier hombre que tenga sentido del
estado en el sentido más profundo de la
palabra respecto a lo que significa la
administración de la iglesia en un
sentido pastoral pero también un
político
debería haber hecho esto hace mucho
tiempo en la medida en que no podéis
representa una anomalía política una
anomalía en la distribución del poder
un ente que adquirió por decirlo así por
la estructura que se le otorgó un
un estatus a donde no rinde cuentas
donde no logra estar regulado donde
tiene problemas de secretismo de estar
incrustado al interior de la institución
especial de una manera bastante anómala
entonces creo que normaliza un proceso
que contribuye al buen gobierno de la
institución eclesial en su conjunto
my que pasó a preguntarle ahora por el
tema de la sociedad
no sé si cuál es su interpretación si
usted lo lee así si hay una cierta
desconexión de la iglesia católica como
institución y la sociedad actual no voy
a entrar a discutir el tema efe es
completamente respetable que las
personas crean en algo en algo superior
pero la iglesia no es una institución
anacrónica para la realidad social en la
que estamos en este momento cuál es su
interpretación
la iglesia católica es una institución
múltiple y diversa la jerarquía el clero
con gran parte del clero de la la
la iglesia católica si efectivamente
viene en una desconexión
y de sus acción cultural preocupante no
sólo con la salud mental de ellos sino
que además por el discurso que empiezan
a desarrollar digamos en esa disociación
y en esa desconexión
pero la iglesia católica tiene también
otras organizaciones al interior otra
organización es de fieles red es cierto
católicos de a pie que lo llamara
también que están involucrados en
muchísimas organizaciones sociales y que
no ven o que no hemos visto es cierto
que una lucha social por algunas causas
cierto tenga contradicción con ser parte
de la iglesia católica como como laico
como seglar eso américa latina ha tenido
siempre una historia de compromiso
poquito y nuevos cientos de los
católicos de los cristianos y entonces
ahí no hay desconexión ahora mientras
vas a subir la escala si más conexión
hay porque en eso consiste en aislarse
es cierto concentrar poder y eso ahora
yo quisiera agregar algo sobre la
reforma entonces si se puede seguir
adelante adelante mike porque porque hay
o sea que tomando lo que decía algo no
ramis
lo que lo que el poder digamos que pueda
desarrollarse con esta reforma es bien
interesante yo no creo que ser un
intento de concentración de poder del
pavo porque porque el el 5 de junio
de este año entró en vigencia la nueva
constitución que rige a la curia romana
y es una cirugía mayor bastante
importante que se le ha hecho a la curia
romana han desaparecido muchas
congregaciones internas se han fusionado
en dicasterios se han reducido los
privilegios se ha impulsado un
adelgazamiento acierto y además una
autorización por decir así de cierto de
la vía de la curia y en ese proceso de
reforma en ese proceso de reforma está
inserto esta reforma en particular y
entonces la congregación para el clero
donde ahora está expuesto ser todo el
opus dei es una congregación que un
dicasterio cierto que va a tener mucha
más influencia a la que tenía antes
clara porque va a tomar un impulso muy
grande respecto de las prioridades de
evangelización de esta reforma de la
curia no se hacía
no se hacía desde juan pablo segundo
entonces no es que el día de mañana otro
pontífice va a rehacer la reforma o sea
eso sería un golpe prácticamente un
golpe de estado de la plaza eso acabar
todo lo que ha hecho un pontífice son o
no creo que ocurra porque además el
psico ha sido muy astuto y ha estado
renovando en el colegio cardenalicio
actualmente el correcto el colegio
cardenalicio que soy mayor va a elegir
al próximo de pontífice es mucho más
joven y por tanto esperamos cierto que
tenga una cierta consonancia con los
procesos de reforma claro que ha llevado
adelante francisco de estos puntos vamos
llegando ya la última parte del programa
pero quería preguntarle álvaro su
opinión sobre estos dos factores que le
preguntaba a mike sobre la desconexión
con la sociedad quería conocer su
opinión sobre eso y si no es una
institución anacrónica para lo que es la
realidad social de este momento no nos
metamos con el tema de la fe que eso
pues ya es otro tema parte cada quien
cree como en lo que quiera creer y
dentro de los marcos de la religión que
quiera pertenecer pero esto como
institución álvaro
bueno yo creo que la iglesia católica
como una institución tan
extensas tan grandes están distribuidas
en los cinco continentes tiene algo de
caleidoscopio con realidades muy
diversas y uno va a encontrar como decía
mike de experiencia de iglesias de base
insertas en la amazonía o insertas en
los barrios populares de todas las
grandes capitales américa latina o de
áfrica con un labor social impresionante
y al mismo tiempo
enclavada en el corazón del poder del
poder del poder del poder económico el
poder político el poder intelectual y
eso simultáneamente y muchas veces en
posiciones antagónicas dentro de los
mismos miembros de la iglesia católica y
por lo tanto creo que en entender la
iglesia el catolicismo exige una mirada
muy amplia donde quepan todas estas
realidades particulares que no siempre
se pueden encender existen movimientos
feministas dentro de la iglesia católica
por ejemplo existe movimiento lgtb y
existen también organizaciones
totalmente contrarias anti feministas
y ambos disputan por decirlo así la
representación del catolicismo en la
actualidad claro ya me quedan pocos
minutos álvaro le pregunto por estas
acciones que ha hecho el padre el papá
francisco perdón como lo veamos por
ejemplo en su viaje a canadá pidiendo
perdón por la forma en que actuaron
algunos de sus sacerdotes
en años atrás en algunos internados con
la comunidad de indígenas canadienses ha
pedido perdón en otros escenarios
también parece tal vez el hecho más
reciente que lectura si usted de eso muy
puntual por favor
creo que es un objeto histórico
relevante pero que no ha sido replicado
por los obispos en todas las diócesis
donde se han vivido procesos similares
particularmente en américa latina
deberían los obispos imitar al papá
francisco y aplicar a sus propios
territorios lo que él ha dicho en canadá
me quedan un par de minutos para cerrar
el programa entonces hago las
conclusiones dentro de este marco de las
reformas dentro de lo que está esta
reforma que estamos analizando en
particular para el opus dei- le preguntó
entonces a mike a modo de conclusión que
vamos a ver entonces haciendo pasos
hacia adelante en cuanto a reformas de
la iglesia católica por parte del papá
francisco que vislumbró está en el
panorama
bueno yo yo supongo que es lo que tiene
ahora tiene que ver o debería tener que
ver con
una preocupación que ya estaba al deber
francisco que es la preocupación por el
abuso sexuales del interior de la
iglesia tanto de
niños niñas adolescentes y también de
adultos
allí hay todavía según un sector cierto
de resistencia y debería francisco a
guardar esa temática hay en la reforma
de la curia también hay una reforma a
los tribunales septem hay una reforma al
sistema jurídico pero ese debería ser
sin duda un punto en que francisco
todavía está en debe con las víctimas de
abuso sexual al interior dimensión
álvaro su conclusión para el cierre del
programa qué más podemos ver en estas
reformas en un futuro cercano en los
próximos meses por parte del papá
francisco
yo creo que el lugar de la mujer en la
iglesia católica no soporta ya el grado
digamos de misoginia y machismo que hoy
día espera y por lo tanto uno esperaría
un gesto que institucionalice las buenas
intenciones que el papá francisco ha
manifestado de cambiar esa relación de
poder durante los 10 años de pontificado
que ha llevado adelante entonces
esperamos que pueda al menos instalar
las bases para un cambio en ese campo
tenística álvaro ramos y mike fund trek
en chile en santiago y en valparaíso les
agradezco por haber estado con nosotros
y haber hecho este análisis entender un
poco este tema de la religión que
siempre resulta un poco espinoso hay que
tomarlo un poco con pinzas tratamos de
abordarlo de la forma más respetuosa
posible pero poniéndolo en perspectiva
para explicarlo a la audiencia de france
24 gracias por haber estado con nosotros
ustedes pueden seguir dejando todos sus
comentarios y sus preguntas a través de
las redes sociales y pueden seguir por
supuesto en sintonía de france24 siga
con nosotros
[Música]